when I was a junior in college from the
back row of a darkened Auditorium I
listened to the CEO of a clean energy
developer describe an amazing new
technology that could produce a lot of
clean electricity and reduce a lot of
emissions it was a project called Cape
wind and a audacious plan to drive
130 massive offshore turbines to the
coast of Cape cot Massachusetts
supplying enough clean electricity to
supply more than 300,000 homes and
eliminate the need for a midsized
emitting power plant it was one of those
moments that inspired me to a career in
clean energy and climate policy now in
the 20 years since that night we could
have built literally thousands of those
turbines up and down the US East Coast
but instead we have built literally
six total turbines in the US East Coast
now that's because a combination of
wealthy Coastal land owners both
liberals and conservatives don't like
those turbines spoiling the views from
their Sunset cocktail parties who knew
they could agree on
anything now Cape wind had broad public
support more than 80% of mass Mett
residents were in favor probably because
they realized that sighting the turbines
12 mil offshore makes the barely even
visible to the naked eye but the project
was styed using regulations designed by
environmentalists to protect the
environment instead used by a wealthy
few to protect their
views tragically Cape wind is far from
unique regulations and lawsuits have
been used to slow down or stop hundreds
of clean energy projects in this country
from Renewables like geothermal to solar
to hydro to new nuclear plants to
pipelines carrying captured carbon
dioxide to new transmission lines many
of those projects have been killed many
others are still stuck in permitting
Purgatory now there is some good news
recently alumni of Cape wind have teamed
up with a massive Global energy
developer and are finally going to put
Steel in the water off the coast of
Massachusetts later this year but only
after overcoming I quote countless
regulatory hurdles to take a step back
we have many of the Technologies the
engineers even the policies to drive
down Global emissions and solve the
climate challenge but what keeps me up
at night is that government red tape
combined with nimi that's not in my
backyard opposition will get in the way
now like literally right now government
needs to get out of the way and let the
private sector build clean
energy and as for the rest of us
environmentalists we all need to say a
lot more yes than no in the coming
decades so free enterprise can get out
there and do the hard part now you're
probably getting the sense that I'm not
your typical environmental
Warrior I'm not a socialist or a member
of a green party I love being in nature
but I don't own any birken stocks I can
see that free markets deploy clean
Capital faster than any other force on
the planet which makes calls for
degrowth or ending capitalism deeply
irresponsible to both environmental
progress and human flourishing I run an
American clean energy energ nonprofit
organization called clear path we
advance policies that accelerate
Innovations to reduce and remove Global
energy emissions we spent a lot of time
understanding clean reliable 247 Energy
Systems in order to build those we got a
lot of work to do in very little time
for starters we have to transform the
American power system now all roads to
net zero emissions in the United States
start with making this system system
100% clean but then because we have to
Electrify so much more of our economy
this system will need to at least double
in size maybe much more now it took 125
years to build the system we have today
and if you're like me targeting 2050 for
Net Zero means we have to accomplish
that in the next 27 years that
translates to 10,000 new clean energy
projects just in the US just this decade
and every single one of those projects
starts with a permit to build now
tragically in the US since the
1970s well-intentioned policymakers and
environmental leaders have designed a
worldclass apparatus for getting in the
way let me give you an example NEPA
which I promise is the only boring legal
acronym I will use today stands for the
National Environmental Policy Act nepo
was passed in the 1970s with the
intention to get developers to
understand the environmental impact of
their projects and to show that they had
considered lower impact Alternatives
makes a lot of sense but NEPA was passed
before the modern clean air clean water
or endangered species acts and crucially
NEPA gives outside stakeholders the
right to sue over government regulatory
decisions and now wealthy outside
stakeholders use NEPA suits to slow down
and kill clean
energy regionally things are also in
gridlock did you all know that here in
Detroit this beautiful electricity
system is managed by a massive supergrid
that procures electricity from
independent generators all over the
Midwest and moves that electricity to
factories and cities and homes through a
power Market sounds great right the
problem is the line to connect a new
clean energy plant into that power
market now extends to almost 4 years
Nationwide and at the state and local
level elected officials are also putting
up walls to specific kinds of clean
energy in the US 12 states still have
some kind of a moratoria on new nuclear
energy for example now I will let
somebody else do the talk on the amazing
benefits of nuclear energy but suffice
it to say that putting 24/7 clean
reliable energy off limits doesn't make
a lot of
sense and we now have lowincome
communities across the country also
voicing opposition to new clean energy
projects which is understandable because
they have borne the brunt of
environmental pollution in the
past so now we have communities across
the country rich and poor all saying no
instead of yes this movement goes well
beyond nimbyism some folks have called
it banana ISM that's build absolutely
nothing anywhere near
anything sad sad and this isn't just a
problem in the United States in Germany
there's been opposition to new offshore
wind even as they're shutting down their
nuclear Fleet for ideological reasons
and you're getting a sense of how I feel
about that there's also been opposition
to new wind in Norway while Australia
has banned new nuclear even as they've
said they wouldn't shut down new coal
the list goes on around the world now I
have just painted a pretty gloomy
picture and most folks who know me know
that I am a sunny optimist so here's the
part where we get to begin a new with
the end in mind it starts by realizing
there is a very important role for
balanced environmental regulation here
in the US we all benefit from the Clean
Water Act passed at a time when our
heavily polluted kayuga river literally
caught on fire but the solution to our
permitting emergency begins with all of
us
environmentalists we all need to support
new build and retrofit clean energy
projects of all kinds regardless of
whether they're things we've been
specifically for in the past carbon
dioxide pipelines aren't so bad to look
at especially compared to the impacts of
climate change that they're meant to
mitigate and this seems trivial but
develop ERS need to do their part to
make their projects more visually
appealing just look at the way these
Advanced nuclear developers have
reimagined their designs to incorporate
nature and welcome in the local
community we all need to elect local
officials that support new build clean
energy and reject regulations that get
in the way at the regional level we need
to encourage those super grid operators
to modernize their processes they could
review applications systematically in
clusters rather than one at a time doing
that could save 2 years from the average
project timeline and making that change
could rapidly bring a terawatt of new
energy generation into the US system the
vast majority of it clean that would go
a long way towards that doubling of the
grid all
clean lastly we need to encourage our
federal policy makers Congress and the
administration to reform the rules that
govern our National Environmental laws
in 2005 during an energy crisis we
actually made it really easy to permit
new oil and gas production on public
lands in the United States to improve
energy affordability why don't we give
clean energy developers the same kind of
leeway now during this great National
challenge we should automatically permit
some classes of clean energy that have
very little local environmental impact
think a new solar site or nuclear plant
on a ground field site like a retired
coal plant we can audit them later to
make sure that they're complying with
environmental laws and for those
projects that do have significant
environmental impact let's make sure
that their reviews are done in a year or
less that the lawsuits are brought in
three months or less and that we
adjudicate those suits in six months or
less doing that alone could shave 5 to
10 years off of project timelines
Nationwide
other countries serious about building
clean have already started to make some
of these reforms Spain for example has
eliminated those upfront environmental
statements for some classes of clean
energy and they saw projected
installations increase 20% in a matter
of months to put it simply if we're
serious about getting a net zero anytime
soon and solving the climate challenge
let's get to yes green light
approved yes in my backyard tens of
thousands of times all over the world
let's get
building thank
you